he's making lists he's checking it twice
here's something interesting
playing Santa I'm making a list and
checking it just the once because let's
be honest it was time to double check
anything during the holidays to see who
in politics this year has been naughty
and who has been nice you think that
would be easy but as with everything in
politics there's very little we can
agree on even during the holidays one
party's nice is the other party's
naughty up is down dogs and cats living
together but we did our best to round up
a few top winners for each of the lists
and if I'm being totally honest thanks a
lot to Special Counsel Robert Muller who
did a lot of our work for us this year
to the naughty list first these are the
people getting my cast off Warby
Parker's and there are lots of them in
their stockings stay tuned for that
first up former Trump Attorney /
personal fixer Michael Cohen Cohen
admitted the line to Congress about his
conversations about a Trump Tower Moscow
development project if there's one group
of people that does not like being lied
to it's Congress also federal
prosecutors double-whammy there how do
you top that well by being Paul Manafort
of course side bar who can wait for the
inevitable Netflix documentary being
Paul Manafort oh man
it's gotta be great stuff in that anywho
the former Trump campaign Chairman is
not had the best year first Manafort was
convicted by a jury of his peers I'm
eight counts including tax and bank
fraud that's not good
then Manafort cut a deal with Muller
special counsel team and then reportedly
broke that deal by lying to the Muller
team all the while reportedly back
channeling information about the Muller
investigation to Trump's attorneys what
sidebar are we sure Special Counsel
Robert Muller isn't in fact Santa Claus
consider this he knows what people are
hiding he puts them on his very own
naughty list he's got a secretive team
of people working for him and he's
delivering big things maybe in December
I mean have you ever seen Santa and
Muller in the same place think about it
also on the naughty list former attorney
General Eric Holder who was anything but
nice when he had this to say about the
Republican Party when they go low we
kick them nah man but that was nothing
nothing compared to what actress turned
a New York gubernatorial hopeful and
loser Cynthia Nixon did now I don't eat
carbs
gotta stay at my fighting trim 180 I
wish but I do respect carbs I'm like
Nixon who got a lot of flack for her
bagel order lox and a cinnamon raisin
bagel right she didn't get nearly enough
flak if you ask me she lost her primary
but her lasting legacy will definitely
include that bagel what a monster and
I'm putting Florida I noticed did you
think we forgot about the 2000 ballot
issues and that Gore versus Bush race
were you not getting enough attention
all sad and the words of my grandmother
at Christmas dinner get it together
your 173 years old now act like a big
boy and who you ask out shone the
Sunshine State and earned its place on
the nice list okay get ready there's a
shocker the United States Senate that's
right for all their squabbling and
partisan missteps the upper chamber did
at least one very nice thing for one of
its own in April when it changed the
rules about having children under the
age of 1 on the Senate floor now this
was largely done for Illinois Democratic
senator Tammy Duckworth who earlier this
year became the first Center to give
birth while in office Duckworth and baby
Miley could be seen around the capital
including on the newly inclusive Senate
floor the rest of the year
okay there you go Senate and on the
other side of Pennsylvania Avenue sinner
will be popping in to give a present to
First Lady Melania Trump was her B best
initiatives tagline the best it was not
was she secretly trolling her husband by
focusing on internet bullying extra
stocking stuffers if so because let's be
honest that would be a gigantic amazing
troll but optics aside the first lady in
the grand tradition of First Ladies has
taken on projects aimed at making the
world an actually better place she has
visited children in hospital she's
focused on ending
opioid addiction she donated 1.4 million
books to underfunded schools in Malawi
that is literally a ton of books got a
ton of books also on the nice list 2018
midterm voters that's right if you were
one of the almost 50% of eligible voters
who exercise your right to vote in the
midterms you are what is best about
democracy you contributed to the highest
midterm voter turnout since 96
that was my beatnik clap also dogs Sully
HW Bush not his real name that's former
President George HW Bush his service dog
gave the nation a moment of Oh during
the days after the loss of the family
patriarch and possible 2020 candidate
Joe Biden adopted an adorable little dog
named major recently love of dogs knows
no politics and I personally do not
deserve them sidebar if you're hoping to
find out which list President Donald
Trump made this year sorry to disappoint
that one is between him and the big guy
and by that I mean Santa the President
did a lot of things this year some were
naughty a few Shh were nice and if
there's anything we know about Donald
Trump is that his performance is judged
primarily through the lens of what you
already think about him do you like him
great then you loved what he did in 2018
do you not like him then he is the
Grinch incarnate I can't confirm however
that there was nothing in the
president's medical report about his
heart being two sizes too small his
heart as we all know is the most perfect
heart that has ever beat in any
president nay any human ever it's a fact
now this is not an exhaustive naughty
and nice list and I don't envy the big
guy up north the task of keeping up with
each person on earth behavior all year
long it's exhausting even in the
politics world that's a full-time job
and doing it this year has me ready for
a long winters nap and that is the point
we do this twice a week even during the
holidays join us every Tuesday and
Thursday to avoid getting a big lump of
coal in your stocking